what's up guys
bang bang lunch money time it's friday
friday rebecca black if you know you
know
while while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get our lunch
money right
i am here with the beautiful and
intelligent polita marinova
she finally has gotten in line and has
the uniform on
black t-shirts only what's up how are
you how you feeling about the week
i feel great i didn't know today was
friday i woke up i thought it was
thursday and then i was like wait it's
friday
does it even matter during quarantine
not really not really is saturday better
than friday
yeah yeah all right what's going on with
george soros okay
so remember the man who broke the
british pound so do you remember how the
other day i was telling you that i
really don't like
loans i don't like taking them i don't
like giving them out yeah
okay well george soros has an idea
on how europe can recover from the
coronavirus crisis he
says that the 27 nation group should
issue perpetual bonds which mean that
the principal amount would never be
repaid
only the annual interest payments
they're also known as
consoles that's not something that
sounds like i would like
everyone pay attention you're watching
the intellectual olympics happen on
financial television shows right now
everybody needs to chill out we don't
need to reinvent
all of this nonsense in the financial
markets
george soros is incredibly smart he's
probably one of the best investors in
the world
the idea that we are going to issue debt
that never has to be repaid
isn't that a grant well hold on so
basically what they're doing here is
they're saying hey the government should
uh issue bonds people will buy those
bonds and the government says we're
actually never going to pay you back
your
your initial investment your principal
we're only going to pay you
over long periods of time the interest
so let's say 0.5
interest so you give me a million
dollars i'll give you 50 000
a year in perpetuity but i'm never going
to give you your million dollars back
how does that make sense
well you're you're not an economist and
even you know that that's
uh stupid and so on top of that they
then what are they gonna do with the
million dollars they're raising the
bonds
they're gonna take it and they're gonna
give grants to people
finance does not work
under socialism it doesn't work it's
broken
and so what people have to understand
here is
the whole idea of investing capital
whether it's in equity or debt
is you take risks get money get paid
true get money get paid but if you take
risk
in order to get the reward you have to
take risk what everyone is trying to do
is they're trying to
outsmart thousands of years
old mechanisms that we know to be true
supply and demand economics
risk and reward etc basically what they
want to do here
is they want to have 100 of the reward
and no risk so again this is not what
they want to do this is george soros
uh suggesting to them what to do
you're mistaken that's not how finance
works
george soros doesn't say this unless
george soros has already had that
conversation with people
well for sure because here here's the
whole thing at the end of the day
the way the world works is if you give
money to somebody and you get nothing in
return
you throw off the incentive structure
and it leads to bad
[ __ ] right so the whole idea of we're
going to give people grants
the u.s government gave grants in the
bailout two-thirds of the money that of
the bailout money for the airlines
is a grant if you think that's
sustainable if you think that's a good
idea
i completely disagree the whole idea
that they're gonna issue
bonds and tell bondholders we're never
gonna pay you back but what kind of
if i'm a regular person buying a bond
from the government what kind of person
would do that if they know they're not
going to get paid back
because the thought process from the
bondholder is okay i gave you a million
dollars you're going to give me 50 000
every year for years and years and years
and years and so i'll make the money
that way
what they're what they're missing though
is that
that only works if they actually pay you
the interest
but the the thing you're holding values
guys well it's just not valuable right
they've already told you
you're gonna give me a million dollars
i'm gonna give you a piece of paper
you're not getting your million dollars
back
i don't know like finance and all this
complicated stuff just sounds like
really
fancy gambling in times of
crisis people start to do really dumb
things
right and they get away from the basics
because everyone wants to do
super exotic like weird [ __ ] and try to
be smarter than the market
we know time and again let the free
market rain
take risk have the upside of reward
take risk potentially lose your money
and let the market do its thing
stop trying to short circuit and protect
people because when you do that
you change the incentive structure
because now what i'm going to do is say
hey you know what
i only want to take loans where i where
uh or i only want to uh give loans where
i don't have to get the money back right
right
right why should the government be able
to do that why can't i do that and you
just completely go through the whole
uh waterfall and just sell them in other
words to summarize
if your name is not joe exotic you
should now be
partaking in exotic things you brought
up a great point and you should
elaborate on this because for somebody
who
knows enough about this stuff you nailed
it which is
it's just gambling it's just risk-taking
i don't know it just it sounds very
complicated and the more
complicated things get i feel like
somebody's getting screwed somewhere
oh he's a reporter that is what i have
to be clear that's exactly what
every anytime a billionaire has an idea
somebody somewhere is getting screwed
like
had you ever heard of consoles before
consoles is uh i i think that
i don't think i would agree with my hair
here yeah i mean
you guys know what's going on it's it's
preparing
so the whole idea is uh perpetual bonds
is definitely an idea that's been
floated before i've never heard the word
uh the terminology consoles i don't know
where that came from i just i just said
that
i know but but what i'm saying is
perpetual bond is basically another way
to say
we're never giving you your investment
back good to know if somebody ever wants
to give you a perpetual bond say no no
no
yeah but if you want to give out
perpetual bonds i'll be the lender no no
no
oh no i'll lend you a perpetual bond i'm
not talking you give me your money i
just never give it back
all right that's why i'm against loans
next gold bars
okay so polina has identified
wall street and just tore it down into
you guys are all just gamblers
you're not wrong okay get money get paid
these
two ten-year-old kids in france were uh
playing uh making a fort in their
grandparents uh
you know house and they found something
wrapped up in old sheets
and it turns out it was two gold bars
that their grandmother had bought back
in the day
they're worth a hundred thousand euros
combined and they're going to be
auctioned off but it was so funny
because
until he saw the gold bars the kid's
father thought they had found his
mother's antique
knife holders sibu play merci
in the that's french for get money get
paid these two little 10 year old kids
stumbled upon a hundred thousand dollars
worth of gold
kind of said they're not just giving it
to the kids like why are they auctioning
it off
well i mean if you're a 10 year old kid
what are you gonna do with two gold bars
actually there's two kids two gold bars
they just each get one see their mistake
was they told their grandfather or their
parents or whoever that they found it
if you were a real gangster you just
wouldn't tell anybody you got the gold
bars you just put in your backpack and
go home
they they they are very heavy uh they're
like a kilogram each
what what is that song uh no you know
what i'm talking about in france
that that's something about threesomes
that's why i know that song
uh all right anything else about gold
bars by the way
yes it is what is it about it means
do you want to sleep with me tonight
that's what it means oh a threesome
whatever
same thing i knew this about sex um
there are children watching this program
you need to
earmuffs earmuffs earmuffs little kids
remember the two-year-old who goes bang
bang
all right what's going on magically so
okay
this is absurd because at this point if
magic leap can raise more than three
billion dollars i should be able to
raise
um more than three billion raise 350. no
they they raised 250 million
on top of their previous two point
whatever
billion 2.6 i think 2.6 billion well
they just fired 50 percent of their
staff
that's the big deal so do you remember
magically was trying to get sold
looks like nobody will buy it who the
hell is giving this company 350 million
dollars
so well hold on back up for a second
magic leap basically is a company that
has built
uh it's a vr or ar uh so virtual reality
or um uh augmented augment is reality
you put it on and you can see cool stuff
so literally everything from in an
operating room
you can see a heart beating there and
then you can walk around it and do all
that stuff
palpating uh and then you can also
do things like go into full vr all this
kind of stuff it supposedly has the best
technology that
a lot of people have seen uh but they've
never actually launched it publicly
and so they've raised over three billion
dollars they were trying to get bought
for 10 billion dollars
a couple of weeks ago the reason why
right again to understand the mechanisms
of how fundraising works
if you raise three billion those
investors want to return on their money
so you can't just sell for three billion
sell for more 3x that is you know around
10 billion
nobody did it so then they turned around
and said oh we're gonna cut fifty
percent of our staff they fired about a
thousand they're blaming kovid
of course everyone's gonna blame coped
uh they cut a thousand people and they
just raised 350 million dollars
now i actually don't have a problem with
this and i think that
uh what happened if i remember correctly
is it's an inside round
inside round meaning they didn't
disclose who the investors are so i
don't know if it's an inside round
i read the internet i think it's inside
round uh and so basically an inside
round means that the existing investors
invest more capital they don't go out to
other people and
it's kind of like you're you're pot
committed right it's kind of one of
these things where you're like okay
i've already invested two billion
dollars or two and a half billion
dollars you know what it's like
it's like when you're in a bad
relationship and you're like oh [ __ ]
i've already been in this relationship
for six years i have to keep
investing instead of cutting your losses
and getting out the hell out of here
and that is what the magic leap
investors do not understand just call me
and i will explain
did she just say that she's in a bad
relationship not me just enjoying
okay all right awesome we haven't been
together for six years
you're lucky that you haven't been with
me for six years by that point you'll be
crazy
next thing you know i'm like america
freedom
and be like wait what it's like oh i've
been with him for six years that's how i
talk now
you don't already believe in that stuff
i believe in it i just don't
yell it you know off the rooftop hey
somebody's got to say it uh so will you
start explaining all the financial
concepts in relationship terms i can do
that yeah all right so what's going on
uh with man in the arena well that's not
a financial thing okay
what is that tom brady has a new
docu-series
um in it on espn and it'll document his
journey
to each of his nine super bowls damn he
went to nine super bowls
so this is like keeping up with the
kardashians for sports
wait wait can i tell them yeah of course
last night we watched uh watched as an
aggressive oh
he was pretending to work and i would
just see like peeking out
um the kardashians 10 year like
anniversary or something tv special a tv
special yes on 10 years they're wild
i i didn't know a bunch of stuff they're
wild they all look very different too
like there's a lot of
magician work going on their faces and
stuff i don't know what happened but
there's some stuff going on there my
favorite person though is uh the reason
why
i it caught my attention is there's the
guy what's the guy's name scott disick
yeah that guy he didn't give a f at all
like he was just literally
you see thank you kid kid show uh and so
he was just sitting there
uh on set and he had his feet propped up
on a table and his hands back
and he was just yelling stuff and i was
like this guy literally does not care
he's just he's just one of those people
that's like trying to hang on for his
dear life to the kardashians because
they made him famous and
that's it it's all right kylie's the
real gangster she sold a billion dollars
kylie yeah she's a genius it's all right
man in the arena are you gonna watch
this
so i i kind of are you are you into the
keeping up with the kardashians for
sports yeah
yeah all right did you think that the
last dance was well done
well after reading how all the
co-players
teammates oh teammates that's gonna say
co-players
colleagues in the game his so michael
jordan's teammates how upset they were
with the documentary and called it uh
michael jordan's propaganda i really
hope that the super bowl special
is a little bit more objective it won't
be
when you're when you're the greatest to
play your position or the greatest to
play your sport you can do whatever you
want
you get a rewrite history so so the the
title of this
is the man in the arena tom brady what
did i tell you this morning when i woke
up
the woman in the arena i got upset that
he stole my
title title for what from my documentary
what documentary are you making
i'm gonna make one about my life and
it's called it was gonna be called the
woman in the arena but now like tom
brady's gotta take it
do you wanna tell them what my brothers
thought when we first started dating
no my brothers were convinced oh yes
that paulina was only hanging out with
me to write a hit piece on me they were
they were like yo be careful but how how
badass would that be like after a year
or two and i'd be like
oh just kidding this was just for an
article but thank you very much for your
time and service
that wouldn't be funny at all my
brothers were like literally concerned
they were like
texting me and calling me somebody yo be
careful be careful because i'm such a
gem
like why would i be hanging out yeah
they were like one you're way out of
your league
and two like hit piece incoming oh
you're out of your league
okay of course let's move on all right
bill gates speaking about of our league
bill gates who knows i'm still not
working on a piece
um bill gates so
bill gates every year releases some of
his favorite books
and he just dropped he dropped
the five summer book special you see
you see dj polina is not gonna have a
job for very long
so they're very interesting i even
already bought one of them
i want to read this didn't this come out
today yeah well no
a few days ago but i i read it today but
oh okay so
one of the books you recommend is the
choice um and it's a partly a memoir and
partly a guide to processing trauma
it's about this woman who was 16 years
old when she and her family got sent to
auschwitz
i don't know that's the book you bought
no that's not the one but i will get
this one are you gonna go through every
book right now just i want to say he
says the best business book he's read in
a very long
time is the right of a lifetime by bob
iger so the choice
cloud atlas the ride of a lifetime the
great influenza
and good economics for hard times those
are the books that uh
he suggested uh bill gates smart dude
real real smart guy
lots of questions about what uh what
he's trying to do sometimes
but uh he's definitely a smart guy do
you do you buy into
any of the population control uh
conspiracies about bill gates
no um we're not doing conspiracy it's
not conspiracy it's not conspiracy
theory do you want to know what one of
the most interesting
uh data points on that whole thought
process is
ted turner who is the founder of cnn and
turner
uh broadcasting and stuff uh he has a
um i think it's an autobiography that he
wrote and in it he talks about
how uh overpopulation is going to be one
of the greatest
negative impacts on the uh world and
that's actually
uh and also a strain on food supply
that's why we moved to mars
no but he but he became the largest
private landowner in the united states
or north america
and he's also i think uh the largest
owner of
bison in the world because it was all
about how do you get
food right and like replenish the food
supply
uh but it's all because of population
concerns and so the thought process is
that bill gates
and other rich people understand that uh
population control not in the like
we want to control your mind but in the
sense of uh if there's just too many
people
and not enough resources like you
actually decrease the quality of life
it's crazy okay which which book are you
gonna read
um i haven't decided yet but i think
that didn't you just buy one
i'm not gonna tell you which one which
one did you buy come on guess come on
tell me no
hurry up we're running out of time i'm
gonna get the choice oh but you didn't
get it yet
no okay did you just lie to us
do you guys see that did you just lie to
us no i got another book
what did you get tell us this one which
one
oh my god admit your sins to the people
it's if you guys know what's the title
hold on a second if you guys know the
app headspace um it's about the guy who
started it he was a monk
and it's a part uh memoir part he was a
skeptic about meditation and i want to
learn more
what the headspace guide to meditation
and mindfulness
but i'm also going to get the choice
sounds like some voodoo nonsense it's
not voodoo it's woo
what whatever voodoo whatever you want
to call it it sounds awesome
every time i try to like so i'm trying
to do yoga because i
just like i need to um
i don't know i just i like yoga so when
i'm like do you want to do yoga with me
he's like
is that like stretching yeah i don't
understand why you just call it
stretching
it's not stretching i mean it is no it
is stretching but like why do you have
to come up with a new name for it it's
called stretching
first of all second of all meditation i
hear everyone talks really great
benefits i'm sure many of you do
meditation
for whatever reason i just fall asleep
every time he does
you breathe like every time i've ever
tried i just fall asleep
like i'm like yeah this is super
peaceful see ya
can i just fall over it's not a bad
thing is it but like aren't you supposed
to
get the benefit by not falling asleep i
don't know every time i meditate
which is all like four times i've tried
it i've fallen asleep
you should try it again i might try it
tonight as i'm laying in bed right
before i go to bed
sorry that just like put me to sleep
okay you see how uh
the effect i have on her all right any
other
comments for the people before we get
into the lunch money for the week
nothing i don't think so do you have
something
no i i'm just i'm still shook by all of
your
guys we should start we should start a
hashtag
free not free paulina we should start a
hashtag like co-host paulina or paulina
for
co-host or host are you trying to do a
hostel takeover all right guys listen
hostility take over because i see in the
comments the people are upset they have
spoken
they are saying i am not a special guest
i am the star oh hashtag pulling of the
star
you know what i'll play your game we're
giving away a hundred dollars
it's a little lunch money for somebody
take the url for this video
tweet it use hashtag polina the star
and tell me what the most annoying thing
that pluto does on the show
no and i will pick the best entry you're
gonna pick for a hundred dollars yes oh
yeah of course
i don't know take the url tweet it
hashtag planet of the star and tell me
the most annoying thing that polina does
on this show
and i will pick a winner and we'll give
you a hundred bucks you can go to lunch
save it do whatever you want with your
family once we get out of quarantine you
know what the most annoying thing i do
is
putting up with you that wasn't a good
joke
all right guys friday lunch money time
well while she's trying to get rich the
rest of us just trying to get her lunch
money right
come back on monday maybe we'll both be
here or maybe it'll just be me
see ya